Let's step through this now with
an example of how a minimizer
would try to find the coefficients
of a line that best fits this data.
So keep in mind that we have to
give the minimizer an equation
that it has to minimize.
And what we're going to give
it is that error metric.
In fact we used squared error.
So we might guess an initial C0 and
C1 and that would be a line
like this, and we would give that
to the minimizer and let it go.
So it would measure the error
with this particular line,
it would fiddle with these
values a little bit and
see how much the error changed, try
a new set of values see how that works.
And eventually it's going to iterate,
and
eventually it's going to settle on
what it thinks is the best solution.
So key points here are that
we express the problem for
the minimizer as
a minimization problem and
we give it the equation
to minimize as the error.
And then, what it finds now instead
of x is it finds the values for
these coefficients.
So, let me show you how
to do that now in code.